What are your thoughts on our S.O. Rick Simpson oil? So Rick Simpson oil is very very highly concentrated THC from marijuana
So Rick Simpson oil can be very beneficial. It comes in a little syringes tube because it is like tar in its consistency
Very very sticky if you let it warm up
It becomes a little less viscous and you could manage it a little bit better
But you got to be careful with how much you take if you're going to do Rick Simpson oil it doesn't
Co-direct anything else you're doing because it's not a
Oxygen-izing agent that needs to be taken you know away from any into
Oxidance etc. Like protocell or something so you could do it in conjunction with anything else you're doing better
In fact, we've had people do Rick Simpson oil conjunction with chemotherapy
Now Rick Simpson oil has to be make sure you source it from is a most honest source you can find that they're actually
You know
Yeah, it's a it's a clean process that they're using because in order to extract
The THC from the marijuana plant you have to use some sort of
Extraction process and usually they're using something like ever clear or
Even a simple alcohol, but then no hard no foul because you're heating it up and burning all of that off
now
Person who's making it if you're making it in your backyard you would never make it in your house because you could blow up your house
But if you're making it in your backyard where there's air flowing through
You could choose to take shortcut and to stop the process before all the alcohol or whatever solvent you use to extract the THC is
completely
Aburned off and then you could actually you know sell more of it because boy instead of getting
Eight ounces now I have 12 ounces and I'm gonna be able to make more money
So you want to buy it from somebody who's reputable enough that cares about what they're making that's gonna be
I ask quality for wherever it's gonna end point consume it because that
Solvent that they use to pull the THC out of the marijuana is toxic
You know you could get sick off of that probably that dire anything but you can make you ill and
And the THC concentrate a THC of rick Simpson oil is gonna make you ill enough in itself because you know
I don't know anybody who's ever done
Ricks Simpson oil and said oh this was so pleasant. I just love it. So it's makes you feel super super loopy
You got to start really slow just doing one great of rice before bed
Poor day and then move up to two and then get up to three and then a true rick Simpson oil approach from rick Simpson is
Doing three grades of rice three times a day, and I know very few people have been able to get up to that level
Personally, I've never smoked marijuana before I've never taken drugs. I've never done anything like that
Never hardly ever taken prescription medication. My mom was very natural and how she raised us
That's where what made me want to do what I'm doing
but when I was
The worst of my cancer. I took rick Simpson oil and
Only for all I only did a couple times because I got so
Unbelievably loopy. I thought I was going crazy. I just couldn't do it
I just literally could not do it now. I have I've used THC in liquid form that wasn't nearly the concentration of rick Simpson oil and even that I
Didn't do well
So it's I actually used THC
The other day because my body was just was hurting so bad
I worked too hard in the garden
And I just felt like things flared up, but I could have flared up
some
history and
I did some rick Simpson oil to because I don't like taking drugs. I don't like even taking Tylenol or anything
And I was so unbelievably
It will be the next day. I just
I just I don't know I just have an intolerance to anything so
But not against it. We've seen people have great results
So that I just say really be careful and go slow